for a long time I think there has been
this unfortunate sense that you got the
science geeks over here and you got the
cool art kids over here and that sort of
extends further on into life where
there's a sense that these two worlds
are somehow separate and the fact of the
matter is role in it for the same reason
we're all just trying to figure out the
deep truths of reality I mean think
about a role thrust on to this weird
planet going around the star and we've
given we're all give it a little bit of
time and we don't know what to do with
our time what's important why are we
here right I mean it sounds wubu but I'm
talking about really when you think
about your life what matters and in the
end of the day scientists do what they
do because they're searching for the
deep laws the deep understanding of how
we got here and where we may be going
and artists the ones that I've had
interactions with they're also looking
for the truth some kind of insight into
why we're here and what it's all about
and what's amazingly potent is when
these two communities come together and
allow the underlying insights of science
to inform the poetry of art then there's
some wonderful things that can emerge
because the end of the day they are
these disciplines are not separate these
disciplines are all part of humankind
search for understanding
you